good morning everyone I want to start
today with a question how many of you
raise your hand would consider software
development a dangerous activity ok not
that many of you now how many of you
would consider an activity that
potentially involves hostile or bad
relationships mental or physical stress
and something called a deaf March how
many of you would describe that as
dangerous ok a good number more now what
if I told you that software development
had all those risks and even more I
probably want to take me that long to
convince you because many of you could
probably relate in some way or another
and talking with developers from all
over the world what I found is that
there are a lot of small risks in what
we do whether it's poor working
conditions or horrendously managed
projects or even just abusive managers
and bad teammates there's a lot of tiny
risks in what we do as our job and so
because of that I say software
engineering is dangerous just not
dangerous and the way you might expect
it to be even when we have good salaries
nice offices comfy jobs basically
there's still a lot of risk in what we
do there is in every field across the
world but our field is focused on
creativity right and problem-solving and
really approaching unique and new
challenges and unfortunately it's not so
focused on how we interact with one
another how we take care of ourselves
and how we build our teams and so this
is a combination that easily and
unfortunately leads us to a lot of
stress right and it can lead to physical
mental illness and burnout we see people
leave our industry all the time because
of issues like these and so we can't do
it alone we need a team right but not
just any team we need a team that is
going to support us to take that
dangerous environment we work in and
turn it into a safe one but what does
that team look like what kind of traits
should we be looking for in our team and
in ourselves how do we build effective
successful teams
that's why I want to talk about this
morning and I think it's a great way to
kick off this conference as we talk
about a lot of the cutting-edge things
that are happening and the CSS community
so my name is Trent Lewis currently I'm
a senior UI engineer at Netflix and I
love my job I think it's wonderful I get
a ton of freedom I get to work on things
that interest me and most importantly
they give me free food so what's not to
like about that right but what are the
primary reasons that I actually really
really enjoy the team that I work on is
because it's what I would consider a
safe team and it's this relatively
ambiguous idea of a safe team that I
want us to talk about today
because I would argue many of us don't
actually work on a team like this now
you might say Trent what are you talking
about it's not like I fear going to the
office of course my team is safe but
that's not the type of safety that I'm
actually referring to I'm talking about
safety and a more interpersonal sense a
sense that you can fully and completely
engage with your team and with your work
a sense that you can challenge the
status quo if you need to you can
suggest new potentially controversial
ideas or the very least you should be
able to let your team know when
something about your job or your work
sucks and you're not having fun and
you're not enjoying it but as I
mentioned earlier many of us don't often
find ourselves in situations like that
late last year there's a well-known
management company in the United States
called Gallup and they did some research
that showed that only 3 out of 10
workers actually believed or could
strongly agree that their opinion
mattered at work 3 out of 10 that's an
insanely low number in my opinion at
best that means we have 70% quieter
offices but at worst it means that we
are missing out on 70% of great ideas
that could be changing our team our
community and potentially the world for
better through the use of what we
develop now you might be lucky maybe you
consider yourself one of those three in
10 workers who actually feels their
opinion really matters and if so that's
wonderful
I'm happy for you but it's in your best
interest actually to be striving to
build that type of environment for
everyone else on your team as well
Gallup found that if you could increase
the number of workers that strongly
agreed their opinion mattered to six out
of ten you saw a bunch of benefits such
as fewer team members leaving fewer
incidents occurring and an increase in
productivity now I don't know about you
but that sounds like a win across the
board for everyone to me so sign me up
for that but with all this in mind the
question still remains how do we
actually do that how do we build a team
like this well today I have three short
stories that I want to share that will
hopefully provide a framework for us to
start thinking about what a team like
this might look like so my first
software development job we practiced
code reviews now being a super junior
developer at the time my contributions
were often heavily scrutinized which was
totally fair I was very bad at the time
and who learned a lot from this process
but unfortunately each code review could
take days which meant that even for tiny
changes it would take me multiple days
to land it into our code base and so
after this happened for a long time I
started to get really frustrated right
it didn't feel like my contributions
were valued by the team because they
didn't seem to be a priority for anyone
else so what did I do well I started to
work more slowly I slacked off more and
the result was no one really noticed and
so the lesson that I took from this is
that this team wasn't safe for me from
feeling worthless from feeling like my
work didn't really have meaning that it
was just kind of there as another body
and the result was poor productivity and
lack of engagement with the office and
the work that I was doing now in this
story it would be really easy to say
that the root issue here the root cause
the thing that we should be focusing on
fixing was the code review process and
that it was flawed and that may not
necessarily be wrong but I don't think
it's the root problem oftentimes when
things go wrong we want to point to
something that's really easy to fix
and so what happens is we often fix a
bunch of symptoms and we wind up with a
whole lot of processes rules and
guidelines but root frustrations for our
developers and for our team are often
still there when it comes to building a
great team we need to make sure we're
fixing those deep problems those root
frustrations right we could have fixed
the speed problem of the code reviews by
mandating that every code review be done
in a certain amount of time and we could
have written some code and some bots to
help enforce those time limits but what
would have happened
myself and the other junior developers
on the team probably would have felt
like we were just being a burden to
those senior engineers on the team right
because we're now dictating what they're
spending their time on and that's not a
healthy environment to be in
so that route frustration of being
unsure if my contribution actually
mattered would still be boiling just
under the surface so in this story the
real root problem here is that my team
wasn't good at sharing encouragement and
positive feedback now ironically to
point that out to someone you have to
give them some negative feedback but no
one was willing to actually go that far
and so what happened is I had no signal
that the work I was doing was good but I
had a pretty strong signal that my
contributions weren't that valued so the
answer here is that more process it
rarely ever is often times we can solve
technical problems through better
process or improved workflows but rarely
does that actually help us with
interpersonal problems right instead we
need to focus on fixing these sort of
issues primarily by communicating better
communicating carefully apply some
purpose some empathy to how you
communicate with your team maybe you see
your junior developer and they're
struggling with the code review process
and so be sure that had some positive
comments I let them know they're doing a
good job even if they're having lots of
issues with the code they're submitting
okay or you interact with a team lead
and you see that they're really stressed
out maybe let them know that your
request wasn't that urgent or if you can
offer to take some other workload off
the idea is that our communication both
in our team as well as the larger
software engineering community were in
should always have this constant purpose
of trying to build a better environment
one where relationships are solid and
people actually feel meaningfully
connected to the work that they're doing
imagine the impact these sorts of things
would have on the open-source community
right maybe new contributors would feel
more welcomed and actually want to get
involved more and maintainer x' might
not feel so overwhelmed and burnout is
frequently this idea of communicating
carefully is really just a subset of a
larger idea that I want to talk about
and that is mindfulness which is this
practice of paying attention in a
particular way on purpose in the present
moment and non-judgmentally purposeful
non-judgmental attention to what is
going on around you it's very similar to
what I was just talking about right but
as you might guess from the definition
that I just gave it's a relatively broad
subject but at its core mindfulness is
simply about training yourself to really
engage with what is going on around you
which is why it's often defined by
practices like yoga or meditation other
very structured very purposeful
activities right but maybe you're like
me and you're like no I don't know yoga
and meditation they seem a little new
agey and unscientific but there's been
actually an overwhelming amount of
scientific evidence coming out
scientific research and tons of
anecdotal evidence that these things
actually tremendously improve your
personal life which translates into
benefits and improvements in your
professional life so as a brief example
several years ago the health care
company Aetna started conducting
mindfulness training with its employees
after roughly 13,000 of their employees
took at least one session they found
some really compelling results on
average they witnessed a 28% reduction
in stress levels and to 20% improvement
in their quality of sleep now I don't
know about the rest of you but there
definitely times were actually better
sleep and less stress in my life and if
doing so is going to benefit the rest of
my team then it's really a pretty
compelling reason for me to at least
give up let us give this a shot
so if you're interested in trying this
out I would recommend you start with
this app called headspace it provides a
really nice low commitment way to try
out mindfulness meditation on your own
time
you can build it into your life on your
own time in your own terms
and if you don't like it it at least
provides a really nice way to start an
app so research has shown that
developing mindfulness through things
like headspace actually enables us to be
more mindful around other people and
when you start to be more mindful it
benefits your team because you engage in
more meaningful ways right we stop
thinking about what we could be doing
all the time and instead we focus on
what we actually are doing with our team
we put away our phones more to listen to
people when they're actually talking to
us we close our laptops during meetings
to give presenters our full attention we
show more interest
we've likely all had interactions where
the other person was distracted right
what that conveys to you is whatever
you're saying isn't that important if it
happens repeatedly you start to
internalize this those feelings no
longer is it the thing I'm talking about
isn't important it starts to become I'm
not important and that's really
dangerous if you're trying to build a
cohesive collaborative environment so
try to be mindful be purposeful practice
empathy when you communicate applying
these lessons to all spheres of software
development is only going to make it
much more inclusive and welcoming to
everyone instead of the culture that
many of us experience which is filled
with fear and insecurity fear in
particular I think is a really
compelling reason for us to strive
towards building safe teams because fear
is a huge enemy of innovation in
creativity which brings us to my next
story so on my second job I got to work
on an important piece of infrastructure
for a very large application now I was
still relatively junior at the time and
so I solicited advice from senior
engineers and even some design
committees before deciding to move
forward will we move forward I was super
proud of my work these people I
respected these senior engineers had
said this seems like a good idea
and that was wonderful
but when performance review time came
around it was a different story there
are some problems with the project and
they were ultimately used as
justification to not give me a promotion
now obviously that's a huge bummer but
the real frustrating part was that they
had left comments stating that I had
acted too independently that I should
have involved more senior engineers but
that's what I thought that I had done
and this experience led me to avoid
responsibility in the future I didn't
want to take responsibility be the point
person if all the blame for what I
thought was a team decision was just
going to come back on me eventually due
to that and some other reasons I left
the organization entirely now as before
it would be easy to find a solution to
this problem right you might say oh you
should have got that promotion but the
promotion is just a distraction the real
problem here is that the reality of the
work that I was doing wasn't getting
properly communicated to the people that
could make decisions about it and what
that told me is that this team wasn't
safe for me to take risks on I had to be
careful about the work that I chose to
pursue to make sure that perceptions
wouldn't be skewed and that I would be
reflected the way I wanted people to
know me so this problem is known as
impression management which is this idea
that you have to act a certain way to
ensure a favorable perception of
yourself for other people basically you
need to manipulate them in order to feel
safe we see this all the time in small
ways right maybe you don't ask that
question in your team meeting because
you don't want to look stupid or maybe
you don't challenge that idea that you
think is bad because that might hurt
your chances of getting a promotion
right these sorts of behaviors are
poison to building good collaborative
teams because everyone's more worried
about the impression that they're
leaving than they are about the actual
work that they're doing and that's
really at the heart of what is wrong in
the story I just shared no longer wasn't
willing to take risks to be responsible
because I was concerned about the
impression I was going to leave this
sort of fear leads teams
stagnation and to potentially ruin and
it does it in much the same way as
technical debt and your project does
when you have lots of tech debt in your
project as I'm sure many of us have
experienced especially because we work
on CSS it becomes difficult or in some
cases impossible to make any sort of
major changes and even small ones become
risky right in the very same way when
you have a culture of impression
management and fear of openly sharing
ideas with each other it becomes
difficult and in some cases truly
impossible to enact any sort of lasting
change so how do we combat this how do
we combat this type of culture well we
have to strive in the opposite direction
to build a culture where you can show up
and fully employ yourself in your work
without being worried of negative
consequences to your self-image to your
status or even to your career the
separate environment is known as being a
psychologically safe one and it stands
in direct contrast to that team where
you have to be scared of the impression
you're leaving psychologically safe
teams they feel comfortable taking
interpersonal risks which are things
like suggesting new potentially
controversial ideas to solving problems
or actually acknowledging and owning up
to your failures but then actually
learning from them their risks because
you could find yourself in a position
where you're embarrassed or maybe even
actually punished for your actions by
your team the sort of team though where
you can take these risks give everyone a
chance to contribute their voice to
discussion right they're cognizant of
how they're interacting with one another
and how it affects each other
and research from major players like
Google and even Harvard has shown that
these teams they learn more quickly
they're more innovative and they perform
better overall but how do we develop
this right how do we get to a place
where we're comfortable taking
interpersonal risks with each other the
short answer is you have to start by
experimenting and learning rapidly and I
like to think about interpersonal risks
like software deployments
if you have an effective continuous
deployment setup then the impact of any
one bad commit that goes out is usually
small right if an issue occurs you get
feedback about it real quick you make
corrections you deploy again in a
similar fashion your team should have a
methodology of continuously learning
right if someone makes a mistake
give them quick and timely feedback you
make corrections as needed and you move
forward you don't dwell on issues
unnecessarily and you don't save
feedback for a later date otherwise that
just forgets a culture of scorekeeping
where everyone is unsure of who's
tracking their every move in my story if
I had received feedback as soon as
someone noticed there was a problem we
could have dealt with it a lot more
effectively right we could have learned
from it instead I only received the
feedback as I was being denied a
promotion that doesn't communicate that
there's an opportunity to learn and it
also doesn't communicate that their
safety and taking risks on your projects
all that it really communicates is that
there are penalties for the actions that
you have so the critical point here is
you have to give feedback feedback helps
us build trust and lets us avoid
additional process and it develops
better working relationships between the
people that are involved in it and we
can use those pieces to help us inform
our future decisions to learn faster and
be better as individuals as a team and
as a whole community so give feedback
give it early give it transparently and
give it often to each other learn
rapidly from your failures don't be
afraid of that and be courageous you
have to be courageous to step out to try
to build this culture in your workplace
now there's one last point to hit on and
this realm of taking risks how do you
generate effective feedback because as
we've seen it's really easy for us to
oversimplify solutions to problems or
identify the wrong problem so I'm a big
fan of this model called the five lies
the idea is simple when you're presented
with a problem you repeatedly ask the
question why
why is this happening why did that
happen until you reach an actual root
cause that you should fix
so as a brief example let's consider the
scenario where I push some broken CSS to
production
maybe our site looks like this my
product manager comes over and says why
does the site look weird well I put some
bad CSS why did you push bad CSS well we
didn't test it thoroughly
why didn't we test it thoroughly well we
needed the ship to hit the deadline why
didn't the deadline include time to
properly QA or to test it we did
included in the estimate why didn't we
include it in the estimate
well we didn't consider it to be part of
delivering a future maybe we should
change that right if we have stopped
after the first question here all the
blame would have just been placed on my
shoulders and we would have been done
with it and that leaves developers
feeling unsafe in their position and
that's often what we do unfortunately
because we want the easy fix the quick
fix so the five why's approach here has
this direct benefit of letting you
identify deep issues in your culture the
way you approach working but it also
lets you build a safe team where people
can take smart risks because mistakes
get treated as gaps in your tooling or
your training or your technology not
necessarily as personal failures which
makes it safe for you to take those
smart risks there are two quotes I think
really hammer home this point the first
is that you must never place a worker
only one defense away from failure and
the reason for this is because people
aren't really afraid of failure they're
afraid of being blamed we're all going
to fail at some point it's human nature
some of us like myself might even fail
multiple times in a single day on
occasion accidents and mistakes they
happen but if you spend every moment of
your job in your life worrying about
that you're just never going to do
anything super noteworthy and that is
one unique reason why psychological
safety is so important for those of us
involved in a creative technological
industry it's because it lets us take
risks with the technology with the tools
that we are using see psychological
safety is vital for us to avoid
stagnation to innovate having a safe
team it makes it easier for you to adopt
new frameworks to try out new
programming paradigms like we'll hear
about today and adapt to ever shifting
world of best practices which we'll also
hear about today and those aspects are
really just focused on keeping upright
if you want to be in a position where
your team can actually innovate push the
whole industry forward then you'll need
to take even bigger risks and
potentially wind up in a place where
your immediate team the people you work
with are the only ones that can truly
help you out if you're not a
psychologically safe team then those
initiatives either never get off the
ground or when they do they quickly
quickly lead you to burnout which brings
us to my final story here I was in a
role where I got to work more or less
independently I had a senior title and a
proven track record of being a good
developer and it seemed like a wonderful
world I was really excited about it but
I found that I was unhappy and I wasn't
getting to work closely with others
which meant I wasn't getting feedback I
couldn't tell if I was growing and when
work started to pile up which is bound
to happen from time to time there's no
one I could really talk to about it
which really sucks because I'm a
developer right and so I like to
complain about things eventually I
started to feel burnt out I wanted to
quit I needed help
now I get that it's the dream of many
developers to get to work independently
and autonomously on projects that
interest you but as I've experienced
firsthand there's a lot of risk in doing
this if you don't have a good support
system in place then it's really easy
for independence to just feel like
isolation and when work begins to pile
up you're going to feel like you're
shouldering this gigantic burden all on
your own and you can't just shrug that
off or ignore it there's this
unfortunate vicious cycle that engages
for many developers right we get
stressed out by work but we feel it's
the amount of work that's causing the
stress so because we're smart and
because we think we're very efficient
developers we just work harder we do
more work and we build more stress
thinking that is actually paying it down
but it doesn't
and so this cycle will continue until
eventually you burn out and crash or
someone close to you recognizes it and
points it out to you so the issue in my
story was a lack of transparency into
what was going on and this resulted in
my not realizing the trend that was
forming in my life and my team was also
unaware now before moving into talking
about how we prevent this I want to hit
on real briefly what burnout in work
fatigue actually mean for those of us in
this industry because we talk about
those terms a lot and I think they've
lost their meaning for some folks right
burnout is a serious issue it's a state
of chronic stress that leads you to
physical and emotional exhaustion and it
makes you cynical and detached not just
in your work but in everything in your
life it'll make you feel ineffective
unaccomplished despite any evidence you
might see there the contrary and you
likely won't recognize it until it gets
really bad as software developers are
those of us in this industry
we're very susceptible to this sort of
ailment right because we're hyper
connected it's really easy for us to
stay connected to our work all the time
and since it's a creative pursuit we
have Cynthia often feel a personal
attachment maybe even obligation to our
work as since many of us are passionate
about it we write code in our spare time
that just contributes even more and as I
mentioned earlier our industry is
constantly evolving so you have to be
constantly learning and that's a lot of
pressure so what do you do how do we
combat this when it seems like the deck
is stacked against us well I actually
believe the answer from team perspective
is a combination of the two traits we
talked about earlier psychological
safety and mindfulness right they form a
virtuous cycle that combats that vicious
cycle I mentioned earlier now that idea
might be a bit abstract so let's talk
about some simple examples that you can
try out first idea non-judgmentally
track participation from the rest of
your team alright make mental physical
notes even of who is engaging in your
meetings and who isn't who seems to be
engaged with the team and who's not
who's speaking up this forces you to be
present to be mindful of what's going on
in your team
and when you recognize that someone
isn't engaged you can follow up with
them which will help them feel valued
and feel well like they're actually part
of a team
another easy idea is to simply
incorporate and acknowledge what other
people are saying this doesn't mean
repeat what they said word for word but
try to incorporate aspects of what they
say in your responses maybe something
like hey Sue had a really great idea
about Ziva their day we should make sure
that we incorporate that again this
forces you to be present to be mindful
of what's going on and in turn it allows
your co-workers to feel genuinely heard
and valued now these little tweaks they
probably don't seem like much but they
can have a profound impact on your
team's dynamics over the long haul
but in addition to these little tweaks
we also really need to ensure that we're
focusing on taking care of ourselves as
well to that end I want to talk about
this idea of emotional fitness which is
simply the idea that your emotional and
mental health needs to be looked after
in much the same way as your physical
health does you can't do nothing and
expect to be emotionally strong right
and this impacts your whole life
including your team at work think about
the last time you got stressed out did
you withdraw from your work
well maybe the last time life threw you
a curveball did you handle it in a way
that you were proud of or like me maybe
did you start getting frustrated more
easily and lash out at your coworkers on
occasion these are the sorts of things
that show whether we're emotionally fit
or not and most of us myself included
making a lot of improvement but how do
we become emotionally fit well I would
first recommend you check out some talks
from dr. Emily on hall she's given some
really excellent presentations on this
subject but for now I want to recommend
one really easy thing you can do would
you simply find a couple hours a week to
play and what I mean by play is engaged
in something purely for enjoyment rather
than any practical purpose
all right maybe put together a puzzle
with a loved one start writing that
fanfic finally or pick up an old hobby
right and probably step away from the
computer for a little while that it's
easy for us to think we're relaxing when
really we're still working in some
capacity right which is why I say that
we need to play and not that we need to
relax playing
has been found to reduce stress it
builds better relationships between
those involved in it and it enables you
to respond better when things go wrong
now if you're unsure how do you
intelectual Ian gauged in a playful
activity there's a simple litmus test
you can use which is inspired by this
quote from Niall Horan here's a member
of the boy band One Direction actually
[Music]
he once said when someone asked him why
he wanted to play the guitar more
someone told me in a smile on my face
gets bigger when I play the guitar so my
question for you all today is what makes
you smile more find that and do it try
to do it for at least a couple hours a
week now obviously don't turn it into an
obligation but it will be tremendously
beneficial becoming emotionally fit is
an ongoing process
ongoing commitment but it's one that's
going to help us build a safe work
culture for ourselves and those around
us and it's going to and help you
improve your overall quality of life as
well and to that end I want to encourage
you all to model the behavior you want
to see in your team right I one of my
first days at Netflix my officer came up
to me and said hey you've been here
about eight hours you should go home
there's a really small act but it was
very intentional and what it
communicated to me through both his
actions and his words was that I wasn't
expected to work long hours that I was
expected to take care of myself we need
to take care of ourselves and if you're
in a position of leadership or as
someone that others look up to make sure
you're intentional about setting that
example I think doing these things will
go a long way towards combating burnout
in our industry we work in a very
creative very exciting field right that
offers plenty of rewarding opportunities
but as software becomes a more and more
important part of our society
chances are working conditions will get
worse for many of us because most modern
ideas about how to scale businesses are
geared at repeatedly solving the same
problems through process which is
against this idea of being creative and
being innovative so we have to respond
to this by building safe teams we must
be intentional about the type of culture
we want our team in our environment our
community to have which I believe should
be one of safety
right at this point we've looked at some
personal examples from my life some
studies and even a few tips of how to
build safe teams and I hope that all of
you walk out of here at the end of today
and as you're hearing the other talks
thinking about these ideas but under all
these thoughts I've shared really my
strongest motivating factor is that we
just should focus on making people
awesome people like you all people like
me people like everyone that we work
with all have the ability to be awesome
if they're put in the right environment
to grow and to thrive and I believe for
the vast majority of people that is one
of safety and security one where they
can take risks confidently where they
feel their contributions matter and
they're encouraged to focus on both
their physical and mental health so if
we want to make people awesome then it's
only reasonable that we make safety or
requirement right in the same way that
we make tests a requirement for our
products so that we we can confidently
ship them we need to make safety or a
requirement for our teams so that we can
confidently grow our people there's a
well-known quote that says if you want
to build a ship don't drum up the people
to gather wood divide the work and give
orders instead teach them to yearn for
the vast and endless sea similarly I
would say if you want to build a great
team don't drum up people to just share
their feelings conduct trainings and
implement new processes we have to teach
ourselves teach others to really yearn
for the vast and untapped potential of
everyone around us thank you
you